[Music]
and too much gaming news uh-oh
game I played clash Royale is that the
Instagram thing where they [ __ ] no
it's just like it's just like a little
supercell game I can't play like RPG
supercell like cellular-phone like the
company oh I can't play like longer
games yeah because like you don't have
time to like pick up where you left off
but like three minute game is a little
quick things I'm addicted to those
submitted by bald fingers yeah Oh cuz
you game so hard and their fingers don't
have fingerprints anymore oh I was like
nail list no little hairs like right
here the popular video game for tonight
has been cited in over 200 divorce
proceedings it's bad addictive holy crap
I think wives need to step up their game
if wives are getting defeated by
Fortnight they're not doing a very good
job let's not be sexist maybe it's the
other way around no it's not what if his
husband's crying not in this group dude
I'm with you but because they're
typically though I pretty damn sure like
statistically like 98% it's probably men
that's playing too many damn games and
the wives getting pissed yeah I'll give
it nice even though there's like some
I'd give it that there's probably some
but if you look at the numbers I [ __ ]
put money on that [ __ ] cuz if it were
the husband's leaving the wives were
playing too much for tonight then yeah
you know could be the husbands need to
step up their game but it's I think it's
the wives you don't even need to look at
that [ __ ] to know though ya know but
before video games it would be too much
fishing it would be too much working on
your car it would be too much golf it'll
be too much something yeah but then it
makes sense it's just a stereotype yeah
but now they're just cuz fortnight is so
huge it pretty much I has taken over the
world like everyone plays this game
everyone but us we must be [ __ ] losers
man last time it looks like last time it
was like League of Legends that was the
[ __ ] I think I thought League was gonna
go [ __ ] nuts and then like that was
the last game I played it's like a it's
a really big trend right now like open
world gaming where everybody
kinda gets dropped off into like a giant
hunger game style like one person wins
at the end of that session and it's so
it's not really about killing it's more
so about like stayin alive right and
being the last person what's that one
well the [ __ ] gas creeps up to you
and [ __ ] I think all of them have stuff
like that on well they they always have
like a perimeter that continues like
overtime to like just get smaller so you
pick up guns and [ __ ] you've got a team
and you got a [ __ ] four not
specifically though is where you can
like break down different like buildings
and whatnot to collect like the pieces
in order to build things you can like
build buildings so that you can like go
over traverse new areas or protect
yourself you can like build a fort when
you know so why are you dancing dude
[Music]
damn man yeah so they're saying that so
bit like the two hundred couples that
have cited fortnight that is only in the
UK and that's only this year I imagine
how many other people what if we're all
wrong here and what really goes down is
that the couples get too competitive on
fortnight with each other and then they
get [ __ ] divorces maybe it's got to
happen at least once I mean that only
happens like if the girls so good at
gaming and the guy sucks and his egos
hurt like cuz a girl will never like
fight or care that much about it you
know what me and her are pretty
competitive to divorce him you don't
know I don't think we're that passionate
about what we've done you put up with
way too much [ __ ] to break up with him
over 40 know me girl hangover maybe
that's not right we race on the freeway
all the [ __ ] time if we're both drove
to thee to the office what [ __ ] racing
back home yeah yeah our first dates we
played air hockey and I think we played
like 13 around yeah it kept time well I
got me 11 to 0 whoops [ __ ] what a good
after five videos only person doesn't
that counter only goes like 7 or
something so thanks for putting that out
in the universe Thank You Jo is the only
person that's be me and like my entire
31 years Wow that's because that's
because you are nervous I'm good to go
yeah she is good though she is good
because we had to play a lot to love
them what you're not even gonna pretend
they're not gonna be like that weak
little girl she beats me she beats me at
that basketball game yeah [ __ ] Mario
Kart they're not gonna be sound like one
of my classes
guitar hero yeah yeah something else
outside of this room I'm imagining
myself have an out-of-body experience
hmm man I [ __ ] do all kinds of [ __ ]
better than you that's why I let you
beat me where the divorces are happening
that's getting excited play for tonight
that [ __ ] don't hurt my feelings
what does it hurt your feelings that
she's better than men but you have to
rub it in her face that you're better
than her another no that's why he was
the person that brought up that she's
looking good and she slaughters me in
carnival games I think it was it was me
because because that's what a good
boyfriend does is they lift up their
woman not try to pluck him down that was
the evil one that actually asked I lift
your ass up oh I tell everybody she's
good no I remember
I specifically remember you saying hey
Geo this is the only thing that she's
good at so I hope you win
you bet say that I was there exactly I
will never forget that moment yeah this
is a very red-handed mode especially
with the face I got your back why why
would you do that cuz we're not friends
remember Joe that's - yeah but still
that was like me
why would you do that we're really
friends for all of you that don't think
we're friends no because because
sometimes you know people think you're
playing someone it's like this it's like
this okay it's like this
if someone bullies you it beats you up
don't you want to get your big brother
to help you out and [ __ ] beat up that
blame your big brother
yeah poor air hockey that's what was
happening and you've got you're smarter
and I'm on all [ __ ] next time you'll get
it alright think [ __ ] she needs to be
put in a pace you put me in my place
every [ __ ] day you couldn't let me
have one goddamn thing seven - what a
[ __ ] Joe what I give such a bad boy
you're so mean I lift her like a mother
[ __ ] wait [ __ ] like burn it off my
shoulders on you have no game [ __ ] this
is you're good at that man she's funnier
than you for sure she using me as a joke
that's why if I'm not here she's still
funny yeah she's really she's really
funny but I'm always lifting her up man
don't get no credit are you guys even
competitive we play we play clash royale
but we're on the same team so it I like
co-op I don't like getting into not
anymore
I used to try but then now she's like
ignores me like she's desensitized to my
awesome moves or something I don't know
it [ __ ] it up with that it only works
something like butt naked butt naked you
cannot look away sometimes dick is like
weird like a [ __ ] pendulum it's got a
little slice he knows that's all I'm
looking at so he'll stop doing what
everything he just does max I'm like
that's all I'm really pinging she's
gotta focus on isolation Zoe once you
put good technique into it and it's like
a trip you never think you could see it
like that there's too much information
yeah a little bit point is we play co-op
games
fun are you competitive with Casey on
anything yeah in conversations yeah I'll
be like no no so the way we're
competitive is because Casey the way he
communicates it's like definitive things
like this is yellow like it's not like I
think it's yellow or like this could be
orange it's not like that's how he talks
he's like this is that because it's this
and I hate that cuz I'm like no there's
always these other because he talks in
absolutes so I'm like no it could have
been dancer could have been there you
don't know if that's true you don't know
that so then that's how we like black
and white and you're like good that just
sounds like an argument to me I'm about
like facts and yeah it's like he he's
always saying like he's right and I'm
always trying to find a way to prove him
wrong isn't that every girlfriend that
sounds right though like real this you
know cuz I'll point out to him how he's
wrong so I'm like no how would that I
can't even think of an example or to
really give you guys well everyone's
kind of wrong about a lot of things all
the time for sure probably right yeah
it's not like I'm right either but it's
like I just can't let him be the like
Asian guys with the small wrists or
something oh I didn't find him on that I
was just like alright that's agent guys
have small roots no was that he was
using that to explain another behavior
of his and I don't know what it was no
thanks without you forget you have a
small risk must have a small day stupid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]